there two moments that really made me
pause and think about China one was my
foot one of my first trips to China I
was going around talking to lots of
Chinese about the the relationship
between the European Union and China and
I was asking them what they hoped to get
out of an EU China relationship and one
Chinese academic an assertive
nationalist said to me when when China
goes to war with the United States
we'd like Europe to remain neutral and
that's what he wanted to get out of the
relationship now that was quite an
eye-opening moment because it showed
that whereas most people in Europe can't
imagine their country ending up in any
war other than the kind of war of choice
like in in Kosovo when it was about
protecting the rights of course was it
war hasn't been totally taken off the
table is it the Chinese are obsessed
with avoiding conflict but the idea of
war is still something which is possible
in which they live with as a permanent
fear and that's a a war of
self-preservation which is it which is
quite a different sort of mental state
to be in it's a wider Internet toolkit
then and many then Europeans have when
they think about the world another
really interesting moment was when I
came across a debate amongst Chinese
people about managing that the kind of
the West we in the West
obsess about the idea of managing
China's rise and there is this whole
debate about how do we manage China's
rise what do we do do we try and engage
China do we try and contain them and
there is a sense in a way that it's up
to us to decide how China Rises and what
kind of power train is going to be
rather than something which the Chinese
are going to work on which we're gonna
have to deal with and when I saw Chinese
people having the mirror image of that
debate talking
about the danger of the West declining
too quickly and how that could create
real pressures on China because a lot of
good things are actually done by Western
dominance and they're worrying about
what to do about proliferation and how
to keep the peace if if if if the u.s.
power collapses too quickly as a result
of the Iraq war
and it showed Ava we're not going to be
you know that just as we talked about
trying to manage China's rise and we
work out how to how to mold Chinese
policy they're trying to they're having
exactly the same debates over there and
trying to mold our policies and our
responses and it also showed that you
know they are you know the extent to
which they're thinking about a post
America and a post Western world order